it's got more now on the violence in
Jerusalem and the West Bank between
Palestinians and Israeli security forces
it follows a drive-by shooting and two
stabbing a tank attacks over the past
week in which four Israelis were killed
the fatal shootings of two of the
Palestinian attackers by Israeli police
led to the current violence we spoke to
The Jerusalem Post reporter Dan
Eisenberg what's happening on the ground
right now is not remotely unprecedented
in this country or this region for that
matter what's happening in the streets
of Jerusalem and in the West finning has
happen every year for the last 67 years
the question becomes one of intensity
last summer during Operation protective
edge and following the murder of the
Arab teen mohammad abu khdeir
who was burned to death by Israeli
extremists following the execution of
three yeshiva students in have drama it
was far worse than this during the
Second Intifada there were thousands of
Palestinians in the streets carrying out
acts of violence now we're dealing with
sporadic lone wolves so to speak they
are not nearly as well organized and the
attacks while Hamas gladly expressed
Friday attack that killed a Jew the
reality is that this is not a four-
ground operation at all these are very
angry disaffected Palestinians were at
the end of the rope it appears and
taking lives because of it but it's not
important that perfect by any stretch of
the imagination but the rioting is
continuing as tensions flare over three
home demolitions that were carried out
the homes belong to terrorists who
killed Jews last year the timing is
somewhat volatile to say the least
also this is compounded by negotiations
over the release of a body of a
Palestinian terrorist who stabbed a 15
year old on Sunday morning which police
are delaying because they're worried
that more violence will ensue I didn't
interview with a Palestinian official
from East Jerusalem
who said that there's no amount of
deterrence or police in Jerusalem that
will stop the unrest he said that what
is needed is a political solution
because it's a political problem adding
that more police will only intensify the
problem so it's really a very difficult
situation to navigate do you use force
can you have negotiations do you have a
party to speak to to negotiate with and
these are questions being asked on both
sides with not much success as of now